The by command is going to allow us to answer this
question. So first I'm going to create an r block of code
and I'm going to use the by command. I'll pass a www_likes
as the first parameter and then I'll pass gender as the
second, since that's the variable I would have split our
www_likes over. I want to total of likes for each gender, so
I'm going to use the sum function here. Writing this code we
can see our output. The likes for males is at 1430175.
But it's the females that have way more likes. There
are over three and a half million. It looks like
females have more than two times the number of likes
as men. And while this might seem trivial, information like this
can help websites or other businesses decide which features are
used most often by different subgroups. This might help a
business or a website decide which feature they should continue
to invest in, or which ones they should just leave behind.